like what are the experts kind of the
guys who were have been in the game for
a long time who are they siding with I'd
say the majority of them are signed with
uh Bud Crawford yes that's what I've
seen as well I mean listen I under I
kind of get that right like Bud has a
little bit more magic to his game you
know what I mean he's got a little bit
more of that spell binding ability to
just find the right shot and the right
combination he's a devastating finisher
and remember he was already Undisputed
in another weight class this is the
second wake class Jesus where he's tried
to become Undisputed I think the thing
that people Miss at least as far as I'm
concerned I think Spence well for sure
Spence has a better resume in this
weight class at 147 pounds and you could
probably argue a better resume overall
in terms of who he's fought that one's a
little bit more debatable there isn't
the same kind of Dazzle to what Spence
does and I don't know that that's
affecting how people view the fight but
I kind of feel like it might be